that's what i'm talking about
[Applause]
i don't drink why don't you drink i
don't drink why don't you drink i never
drink
[Music]
and uh connor congrats on proper 12. hey
you cannot say salaam alaikum and
congrats about whiskey
start with that let's start with because
many people there they they get that
what we were talking about that dopamine
fix right right they watch him with the
lewd behavior and
really getting rowdy and not thinking
about okay what does this represent so i
want people who
have had let's say a separation effect
many people now
skyrocketing staggering statistics of
broken homes
sure due to alcoholism rapes
it's happening every like 60 70 seconds
something like that
drunk driving we're not talking about
even what you just mentioned
basically they're saying who the world
health organization
estimates that there is one death
every 10 seconds due to
alcohol alcohol can you imagine that i
think what's more important is that okay
fine the who mentioned
the deaths but what was the recent study
that came out what is the
about zero benefit or yeah there's a
there's a study
if you're a drinker we hate to be the
ones to break some sobering news to you
but a major new study says no amount of
alcohol is good for your overall health
not even that cheeky glass of red wine
you might be holding as we speak on
friday evening a survey in the lancet
medical journal says the overall risk
of liquor outweighs any known benefits
it says
alcohol accounted for nearly one in ten
deaths in people between
the ages of 15 and 49. that data was
recorded in 2016
across all age groups alcohol was
associated with
2.8 million deaths that year before
before i mentioned that okay so what
we're trying to do here is for someone
who's had
because all of these things are in the
backbone because
you might not have committed the direct
crime but if you're somehow you're
complicit in it
you're helping to facilitate something
that's
alcohol obviously and this is this is
one of the things that the major thing
that you get
when now because conor is promoting
promoting his brand
of alcohol beyond the fight so now
i mentioned rape uh i've mentioned what
else uh
breakups breakups of family death deaths
all of these things think of the worst
things and someone in one way or another
has been affected their family has some
how been touched by alcohol
my name is jacqueline saburido this is a
picture of me before i was hit by a
drunk driver
before the car caught fire before two of
my friends
died before i needed more than 40
operations
this is me when my life was just like
anyone else in college
this is me after being hit by a drunk
driver
i grew up with a friend and i obviously
i won't mention his name but we were
in middle school and grade school and
his father was an alcoholic
and i was there on some occasions when
the family would have problems in fights
and it definitely had a huge detrimental
effect on the family
but what was unfortunate is that the son
wound up being an alcoholic as well
right so just think about it from that
perspective copying his father
copying his father so the father was
responsible for breaking
or damaging the family structure but now
indirectly or directly the sun
is following in the footsteps and i know
we're going to talk about this later but
this is why it's even important to talk
about
social media like you mentioned the
dopamine release
media in general and what what values
are we putting forth
through these avenues and means and the
reality is what
you got you know our phone is right here
right all of us got our phones all of us
have
instant access all of us are living on
social media and living on the internet
what is it that we are exposed to at a
high rate
and we have to draw a parable why is it
that
conor mcgregor's alcohol brand is a
co-sponsor
it's because it brings in money well why
does it bring in money because alcohol
sales
are important right and they're it's not
like they're putting
the quotes of very noble and pious men
on the ring or they're putting quotes of
the founding fathers of the country or
they're putting quotes of
you know just a scientist or whatever
whatever you have you
they're putting sponsors under and the
sponsors are those who can
bring the most value or give you the
most money so what is it that we are
really
pushing down people's throat and i think
that's where we should focus let's go to
that study
sure so the study you're talking about i
believe it was in the lancet
it talks about that no amount of alcohol
is good for the human health
you had this common saying that a glass
of wine
alcohol moderation this was something
that people
were commonly known to say and then this
would motivate even the person that was
kind of like health-conscious
then he would read this in men's
magazine but all of this stuff
was funded by the alcohol industry right
so this new study is giving the facts
that no amount of alcohol
not only that now when we look at so
this is the
the one thing we're hitting first we
covered a few other points about the
lewdness and
the disrespect and the behavior the but
this is so important because
i don't think there's many people that
haven't been touched
by the direct or somehow indirect
consequence
of alcoholism what alcohol brings to the
table
and we talked about that one in
one death every second i mean this is
this is by who the world health
organization talks about
there's one death of due to alcohol
every
10 seconds there worldwide 3.3
million people die each year this is
more than the combination of aids they
say tuberculosis and violence
can you imagine that that's not
surprising this is how many people are
dying for many people that
they they they they
are this is the first time they're
hearing this but this is just like can
you imagine every
every 10 seconds uh let me give you some
more look
over there close to over 40 percent
there of the traffic deaths from again
now this is the range of the kids that
are watching him let's say from 16 to
20. some of the young
kids their minds their bodies are
developing and now he's promoting the
alcohol
and almost 40 percent of deaths in this
range
is from this peer group let me give you
another one
it's alcohol is the they say the third
leading cause of death
death and now what does it have on the
economy and i'm just giving you some
snippets but when
people go down this and they start
really looking into it in 2010
they estimated around 250 billion
dollars
in america suffer the economy suffer to
misuse of alcohol
look i think the the summary for all
this is what he is not a role model
right and we have to we have to bring
that into perspective
at the end of the day he can do whatever
he wants and
everyone is judged based on their
actions right what what use what you
reap is what you sow
but the point is why is it that we are
turning to people like him as a role
model so number one something we have to
make clear to the youth is he is not a
role model
in no shape of the matter right we
cannot turn to someone like this and say
okay this is
for example if i were to do or you were
to do what conor mcgregor has done
we probably be in jail let's talk about
that next so we brought alcohol
to the table now compare the contrast
that we try to
khabib let's bring habib into the mix he
was offered
connor tried to offer habib some alcohol
right
i don't drink why don't you drink why
don't you drink i never drink i'll tell
ya
parties and then
habib said i don't drink never drank and
this is due to islam and then he called
him backwards for them then he called
them backwards
but then we just debunked that because
you see i mean is it backwards because
you're trying to
save lives and all these are preventable
deaths right